it is time for this week's pet project
amy lee joins us from nspca
and she has someone really special with
her today how are you doing
all of our animals are super special but
i would love to introduce you to oakley
who is the sweetest girl she's an
eight-year-old uh
bull terrier mix and she is actually
deaf so we
would love to find our special home for
the holidays and and her forever home
but she's a wonderful wonderful sweet
dog she looks like an absolute
sweetheart you say she's eight years old
right
eight years old and you know we would
love to find somebody that actually
knows a little bit of sign language she
actually knows
this she knows she knows some hand
signals
really um yeah she does um and she's
very sight driven obviously she can't
hear yeah so we'd love to find her just
a great adult home
um preferably no kids because she does
startle um she can't hear you obviously
you definitely want to be a little bit
slow when you're approaching her so she
can see you so you shouldn't get too
if you're coming out of nowhere but
she's wonderful she's playful she's
sweet
she's affectionate she'd be great on
walks and she loves playtime i mean this
this girl is really
the whole package she is a beautiful dog
you say uh she's a mix of some sort
right
yeah so we we have her down as a mini
bull terrier mix um
and she's about 45 pounds she's she's 45
pounds of pure love
obviously she's really really great um
you know she
she is going to make somebody's family
complete so this is a really
that you would invite people to do this
with all pets you can make an
appointment
come down and visit a pet spend some
time with the pet to make sure
everybody jives and this would be a good
opportunity to do that especially
because in this case there's a special
need
there is you know with with covet and
we're actually uh our shelter is
on a little bit of a different protocol
right now um all the appointments are
actually by phone so you're actually
going to be talking with an adoption
counselor at length
to make sure that you're the right fit
for our animals um so you're
it's actually all virtual so it's all
over the phone um we're just making sure
that we don't have actual physical
bodies in the shelter at this time
okay i wasn't aware that they're you're
no longer mingling in person so it's
it's virtual at this point
okay things change we'll certainly
update it on the website but for now you
know
you know and our adoption counselors are
great they're really knowledgeable and
you know
she is if you've got the right home for
her if you've got
uh you know a home that that that's
mellow and you know you can
know a few hand signals it'd be great
for her um you know she's a great great
great dog
all right amy thanks so much and we hope
oakley finds a home very soon if you're
interested in adopting a pet
go to nevadaspca.org or call them at
that phone number